Good morning, everybody. We have four speakers, so I'm going to make
a start on time as people are coming in.
I want to thank you all for attending this meeting, and I also want to thank the
AACR and the leadership of the AACR for having the
foresight and generosity to include the whole-body response to cancer now for
several years running.
It has featured on and off, but since Teresa gave the plenary
on cachexia maybe three or four years ago now, it's been an
annual feature to have whole-body response to cancer sessions, and I think that's
a great inclusion in the program, and hopefully that will grow
over the years.
Why is this important? Well, if you speak to patients who have cancer, they
complain of experiences of systemic disease.
They ask very insightful questions.
They ask, "Why do I lose weight and I'm not hungry?
Why am I tired all the time? Why do the therapies not work, and what can be
done about it, and also what can be done to make me feel better?" And so today you
will hear about various approaches that we can take to hopefully
recondition the organism
in cancer progression. Is this an important problem?
The answer is yes, it is. I want to highlight here one of the papers that is in
MedArchive by our good friend and colleague, Ed Resnick, who
has gone through 60,000 patients at MSK and looked at all of
their features in terms of body weight, but
also serum markers and other features, and he finds that
patients have these repeated episodes of cachexia, and Elizabeth will touch
on a specific analysis based on that, and he's linked it to genetic
predispositions as well. So we are getting into the depth now in this field of
understanding prevalence, associations in humans, and
potential causative mechanisms.
So this is really an exciting time to be in this field.
How prevalent is it really? When Ed looked through the data, and some of you might
actually be interested in site-specific cancers, I think you will see here
probably the cancer that you study will feature on
this list. And look at this list down here.
This is 20, 40, and 60% prevalence by 5% weight loss over
six months. How common it is across all of these cancers.
So I'm going to be deliberately provocative here and say whichever cancer you
study, you should always consider the host organism, and you should always
consider about the systemic effects and cachexia in the context of that cancer.
And so I hope that those of you who are new to the field but want to expand
from a specific cancer to cachexia will see that that's a relevant and
important direction to go.
So for the session today, we have four speakers who've made seminal
contributions to understanding cachexia, and thank you to all of them for joining
us today. Essentially, what we are planning to do is
always pair a molecular discovery study or two molecular
discovery studies from the lab with a conceptual framework, and you will see that
all of us are approaching cachexia as a systemic
condition and how the systemic condition is orchestrated from
subtly different conceptual frameworks, and I hope you find those
synergistic as we talk through them.
So Min
Li will make a start talking about the homeostatic
collapse or the collapse of homeostasis in the whole organism, and then
give examples from his lab. Then Mauricio Barrill
Diaz will follow on talking about the sequence from the tumor to the
organism and show you some molecular pathways and mechanisms that his lab
have recently discovered of how molecules and molecular drivers
can reprogram systemic condition.
And then Elizabeth Cespedes Feliciano will talk
about the emerging concept that this is a dynamic
process. In other words, there is reversibility.
There's even reversibility when we look into the current patient populations, and
she will talk you through the large prospective study that she's
leading on cancer cachexia prevalence and
associated features. And then myself, I will finish off
by talking about cachexia as a principle of
signaling into the organism, lending or sort of going
to the origin and also lending principles from
endocrinology and how molecular processes, signaling
processes in the host can reprogram the host.
And I've put here a few reviews that give
our perspective
so that each one of you who is new to the field can perhaps
read up on different angles into this field
and then join us as we try to tackle this important condition.
Min, you're on first.
All right.
Good morning, everyone.
Thank you. First of all, I want to thank all the organizer for inviting us to be
here. It looks like it's going to be a very exciting
session. And our session chair, Janua, has asked us to cover
different aspects of this disease, which was
significantly underappreciated, and now I think become a hot topic,
and I'll cover,
as he introduced, the homeostasis collapse, and I hope
different speaker will cover different things.
It's great to see the room is half packed and great to see
Dennis and Teresa here, who really appreciate to be
the leading and pioneer scientists who found this field and take
us forward. So I will--
First of all, I have nothing to disclose.
And as
Tobias mentioned and himself and Yiping and Dennis and I,
we wrote a review article earlier this year.
We proposed a tumor-centric framework in which cachexia
represents a progressive collapse of systemic homeostasis and
translational strategies guide the mechanisms informing therapeutic
intervention, which could be the leading the future of this field.
And that involve the interaction, the crosstalk
between tumor cell itself and the tumor microenvironment and tumor
macroenvironment, which involve
theSkeletal muscle and adipose
and the nerve and central nervous system as a whole.
So
in my talk, we use pancreatic cancer as a model system.
Other people use lung cancer, gastric and colorectal cancer.
I want to bring to your attention that pancreatic cancer is the worst in
terms of prevalence and percentage of body weight loss in Caucasian
phenotypes.
I don't think I need too much background for this group about pancreatic cancer.
It is the worst cancer of all cancer types.
The only effective treatment for pancreatic cancer is a surgical
procedure called Whipple procedure.
However, no matter how aggressive the surgeons are, only 10%,
15% of the patients are eligible for surgery.
The rest of them, we call it the horse is already out of the barn.
There's not much we can do with it. We're talking about immunotherapy,
virus therapy, oncolytic virus, and small molecule therapy for decades,
until very recently with the new KRAS inhibitor, we start to see
some survival benefit. So there's still a long way to go to treat this terrible
disease. And we desperately need novel therapeutic
strategies and early diagnostic marker for pancreatic cancer.
So
a little background of what I do in the last 20 plus years, we've been
heavily focusing on a zinc transporter, called ZIP4.
This diagram shows the balance of zinc transporter, zinc
homeostasis in mammalian cells. There are two protein families,
ZnT and the ZIP family. They work together to maintain the
intracellular zinc level at a very narrow physiological range.
If you have too little, that
significantly inhibit the cell and body development.
If you have too much, first of all, you get a zinc toxicity, and
second, the chances for developing cancer, including pancreatic cancer,
GBM, and colorectal cancer, are much increased.
So about 20 plus years in collaboration with Craig Loxton and MD
Anderson, that we identified a zinc transporter, ZIP4,
was significantly increased in tumor tissue versus the benign tissue
versus the chronic pancreatitis tissue.
And we found the over-expression ZIP4 significantly increased tumor growth.
And on the other side, you silencing ZIP4 significantly reduce the tumor
growth. If you look at the mouse on the left side, which has a wild type
ZIP4, the tumor developed, the mouse developed all kinds of problem,
lose the body weight, jaundice, and significant tumor growth and metastasis.
When you block ZIP4 with shRNA, those mouse look normal.
They talk normal, they laugh normal, they live a normal life.
But if you open them up, they still have a big tumor in
the primary site. The survival was even
more promising that the
control group, which has higher level of ZIP4, the tumor continued to grow, and the
mouse start to die shortly after one week, after four weeks.
Majority of the mouse died of pancreatic cancer.
When you block ZIP4, those mouse tend to stay alive
until five to six weeks. We also see a similar
trend in the syngenic transgenic mouse model, KPC model,
that 100% mouse died of pancreatic cancer after four weeks.
And ZIP4 knock out mouse, the
survival was significantly improved.
So we have shown the proof of concept of high ZIP4 level
can significantly increase tumor.
But can we use ZIP4 as a target for shRNA therapy?
We talk about therapy, we know that single therapy is never going to fly.
So we tried different combination, shRNA plus surgery, surgery plus chemo.
And you'll be amazed just treating the mouse with different
diet, like zinc deficiencies, inadequate zinc, overdose, that cause
significant difference in terms of overall survival as well.
So before I go into the data, I want to briefly introduce
one of the surgical model in pancreatic cancer in mouse that we first
developed about 14 years ago that requires a two surgery.
The first one, you inject the human pancreatic cancer cell into the
body and tail of the
immune mouse. After 7 to 11 days, we did a time
course. If you do that too early, that's cheating, and nobody diagnosed early
enough. If you do that too late, that makes things ten times worse.
So we removed the whole spleen and majority of the pancreas body and tail and
head.
Fortunately, all mouse survived the surgery itself.
However, just look at survival. There's not much significant different.
There may be two or three times increase if you compare the surgery group,
distal pancreatectomy, versus the control group.
The only difference that we found is the body weight index.
Remember, this was done about decades ago, and the Caucasian is not a major thing
in pancreatic cancer research. We found the surgery group tend
to maintain the
original body weight. The control group, those mouse continued to
lose body weight. Once we lose about 15% to 20% of
the original body weight, those mouse are going to die within the next few days.
So we tried the first combination,
shRNA with the surgery. Now we see a significant difference.
The median survival of those mouse increased from 15 days to 30
days in the ASPC mouse model. In the BxPC3
mouse model, which showed a little bit of
intermediate level of ZIP4, the
median survival was also significantly increased from 57 to 92 days.
And at that time,
most people were focusing on the primary tumor, and they look at the tumor weight,
the tumor size, and the progress, metastasis, et cetera.
So we took the liberty to collect not just the tumor tissue, but also the
muscle tissue, the skeletal muscle tissue, and the gast, and the cell gast.
And also, as you can appreciate in panel DF, that for this
group with wild type ZIP4, those mouse go through
typical muscle wasting. The muscle fiber is shortened, the muscle mass
was reduced, and the grip strength was significantly reduced.
When you treated the mouse with shRNA, that blocks ZIP4,
that the muscle wasting syndrome, the phenotype was significantly
rescued.
So I'll skip all the details with the signaling
pathwayjump to the conclusion that overexpress ion of a zinc
transporter on the surface of pancreatic cancer cells are uptaking more
zinc that activates a zinc-dependent transcription factor.
In this case, it's KRAB that binding to the promoter region of
Rab27b, which facilitate the release of the
Hsp70-90 heat shock protein family, that bind to the receptor
region on the normal muscle cell surface,
that turn on the signaling cascade, starting with P38 MAP
kinase activation, followed by eBP beta increase and
UBR2 and ATGL1 increase, that leading to
a muscle wasting and cancer cachexia in pancreas.
So, since I'm the first speaker, I have the privilege to
briefly introduce cachexia a little bit.
It's a multifactor syndrome that characterized by ongoing loss
of skeletal muscle with or without loss of fat mass.
In pancreatic cancer, it's always with loss of fat mass.
Unfortunately, there's still an ongoing debate of the clinical definition, what is
cancer cachexia,
and apparently involves multiple factors, anorexia and reduced food
intake, et cetera.
And of all those cachexia cancers, pancreatic cancer ranks
number one in terms of prevalence and percentage of
loss of body weight.
In the recent review article that Tobias, Dennis and
I wrote, which cachexia involves apparently
multiple organ, skeletal muscle, adipose, immune system,
endocrine system, the gut and liver and cardiovascular
system and CNS system. You're going to hear this
later on in this section. That talking about signal
network of pancreatic cancer is, for example, muscle wasting.
The majority of the research on pancreatic cancer cachexia is focusing on muscle
instead of adipose. And I think Tobias will talk about
adipose a little bit. This is a very complex signaling cascade network,
involves inflammatory cytokine, Teresa Zimmer's favorite
IL-6 pathway, and the NF-kappa B pathways that Dennis
has been working for a long time. And there's a lot of interaction between
different pathways and cross talks of all those signaling pathway.
And multiple therapeutics has been developed
targeting those pathway. There's recently a very nice paper on
cell that showing the blocking the vagal nerve system can
block the tumor liver signal axis and
increase the survival, and they
reduce this cachexia syndrome a little bit.
And GDF15 monoclonal antibody that was developed by Pfizer
has gone into a Phase 3 clinical trial.
So we didn't have any drug specifically targeting pancreatic cancer
cachexia, now we have a little bit of
drug in development. So I'm very much looking forward to new drugs
being developed in the next few years targeting of those signaling
pathway in cancer cachexia.
So
we recently have developed
a very interesting mouse model, and used that.
We have
demonstrated the multiple factor, multiple pathways are heavily
involved, participating in pancreatic cancer cachexia.
For example, a circulating RNA called NPPC7
serves as a tumor suppressor gene that functions through a feed-forward
loop and leading to a zinc-dependent pancreatic cancer
cachexia. In another study that showing under metabolic stress,
the ACSL2 can turn on expression of ZC4
and induce the TWIL1-mediated
muscle wasting. At the same time, the SDC1 induce the
macropinocytosis pathway, that at the same time it chop down
its own muscle fiber and tissue and feed them back to tumor cell
through the increased pore size on the cell surface.
And Julia wrote a very nice commentary on this
work. A couple of years ago, we have
identified that macrophage play a central role, a very critical role
in terms of pancreatic cancer-mediated muscle wasting and
cachexia, that
the cancer cell alone and the macrophage alone does not
increase the TWIK, that was the major mediator for
muscle wasting in cancer cachexia.
In another study that we recently published early this year, we found the
central nervous system, especially that GDF15 was
heavily involved in this tumor immune neural circuit that
promotes cancer-induced cachexia.
In cachexia mouse model in human samples, the
nerve infiltration and macrophage infiltration was much
increased that the GDF15 seemed like to be highly expressed in
macrophages as well.
And this CSF1 up-regulated GDF15
seems to drive the cancer cachexia and
anorexia, which is loss of appetite, by shifting the fuel
utilization pattern.
A typical metabolic shift from lipid
oxidation towards the carbohydrate usage.
This is a summary showing that
starting from tumor cell that activates the CSF1, that recruits
and educate and reprogram macrophages that secrete more
GDF15, and works on neuron systems through
NE that form this feed-forward loop, and driving cancer cachexia,
energy expenditure and anorexia as well.
And we also invited to write a review article talking about the
tumor-driven disorder of the whole-body homeostasis.
I want to thank the
guidance and the significant contribution from Tobias and Dennis, who's
also in the audience today. And this was also
commented by the Australia Cachexia Group.So,
in the next ongoing study
that we have spent a lot of time and effort, this is a three-year
work that we collected more than 50
pre-cachexia, cachexia, and non-cachexia human samples.
And we use a single-cell sequencing and spatial transcriptome to identify
and isolate which subpopulation of the tumor cell, which
subpopulation of the macrophage, which subpopulation of the cancer cell
that work together to drive cancer cachexia in pancreas,
and maybe in other cancer model as well.
So I want to
stop here and
summarize that what we have done in the last 20 years
from the identification of a single molecule, which is
up-regulating tumor cell in pancreas, which is typically what we did
20-plus years ago, and expand our research to multiple
function with this molecule,
to multiple cell types, and to multiple organ system.
And to
indicate that this itself is a holistic oncology
problem. It's the whole body homeostasis disorder, not a
single organ, not a single cell type,
disease. So I want to thank my funding source from NIH and
all the people who are involved in this work.
And I will stop here and give 10 second back to
Tobias. Thank you.
And we will take a few questions after each talk, so come forward if you have a
question.
Just
a quick question about the pre-cachexia state and the signature.
So that was in the mouse model, the last slide you showed.
And can you find that in patients? And once you hit that state, do you
always move towards cachexia state?
It's a very good question, yeah. This whole field is still struggling with the
definition, what is pre-cachexia, what is cachexia, what is non-cachexia?
So we did collect a number of cachexia
human samples and non-cachexia, which is easy to identify.
You look at the patient in the last six months, three to six months, you lose 5%
body weight. That's considered as cachexia.
Who lose less than 5%, it's non-cachexia.
However, if you look at, and take into consideration of
BMI, apparently, a patient who weighs 100
pounds and lose
10 pounds is a big deal versus the patient who
weighs 200 pounds. So
we found there is small percent of the patient who does not qualify as
cachexia, but apparently, they lose some body weight, so we consider those patients
as pre-cachexia. Now we're developing a mathematic model to
sort of stratify a patient who is non-cachexia, cachexia, and
pre-cachexia. So we hopefully will have an answer for you in the next few
months. Dave?
Min, a terrific assortment of observations that you were
able to go through in such a short time period.
Have you ever looked at trying to regulate CREB?
If this is your
basic
pathway, why not just regulate the transcription factor that is downstream
of the perturbation? There are ways to think about doing that.
Is that part of your portfolio?
Mm-hmm. Yeah. Well, the problem is,
CREB and many other zinc-dependent transcription factors, they regulate
multiple downstream targets.
We're worrying about the non-specific
side effects. And also, thanks for your suggestion.
We have been thinking about combining the KRAS inhibitors
in this system as well. So we're started doing that, but
with serious concern about the side effect.
Yeah.
Ashok.
Ashok Saluja. Min, congratulations.
Having three articles in one issue of "Cancer Cell" is an
achievement.
Thank you.
So
what you are suggesting is that instead of lipid oxidation, you have more
carbohydrate as source of energy
for these.
But there's not whole lot carbohydrate reserves in mouse
or even in humans.
We have what? Half a pound or a quarter pound of
glycogen.
So how does this work then? If there's no lipid
oxidation, they should lose weight like crazy, no?
That's a very good question, yeah.
Tobias asked me to cover the
energy expenditure part. So our data
using the metabolic cage, which is a very sophisticated system
that's showing how much you eat and which part of the
food and the consumption, the body weight index, and temperature, et cetera.
It gives a whole bunch of data that it shows clearly there's a switch
from fuel utilization from lipid to
carbohydrate. And you're right, the
glucose metabolism significantly decreasing pancreatic cancer.
There's a whole bunch of other-- We're having to figure out why this is happening,
but it is happening. So in the future, we may be
able to pinpoint which part of the
carbohydrate
utilization versus the lipid oxidation, the ratio
and the timing, for example. That clinical data shows, especially
from group at MD Anderson, that adipose loss
happens way before the
muscle wasting, and way before the first diagnosis of pancreatic cancer, probably
as early as nine months.
That could turn into the very interesting early
detection for pancreatic cancer.
But we're working on the
logistics and mechanism. What is happening in terms of timing and
spatial wise of the whole process.
Thank you. All right
Hello everybody. So, I would like to thank the
ACR and to BS for putting together this nice
session and to giving me the opportunity to share our
work and efforts to find some novel
mediators of cancer cachexia. And these are
my disclosures.
So,
there was already a reference to this review article that we wrote some
time ago, where we tried to define cancer
cachexia as a multilevel metabolic dysfunction, defining
the tumor as the primary initiator of a process that
eventually results in wasting and a direct
effect by the tumor. But then there are underlying host
responses to the cancer that further
aggravate wasting. And on top of
this or below this, there is also tissue crosstalk between different
peripheral tissues and the brain to further induce
wasting. And
so we are trying to look into these different levels of dysregulation,
eventually leading to
wasting. And as one example for something that
has not been studied so extensively in the past, but it
receives more attention recently is, for instance, the role of the liver.
And there are some work showing that the liver is
severely affected in cachexia, for instance, than
the main process of muscle atrophy
and proteolysis that results in the release of amino
acids. These amino acids can be used to also in
the induced acute phase response by the liver that then leads to the
secretion of acute phase response proteins, probably also
contributing to systemic inflammation.
And these amino acids can also feed into
gluconeogenesis, which is found to be induced in
cachexia,
and
might also be part of a kind of Cori-like cycle
between the tumor and the liver, where glucose from
gluconeogenesis feeds into tumor metabolism,
and then the resulting lactate from aerobic glycolysis
can also feed back to drive gluconeogenesis in the liver.
Then steatosis had been described in cachexia, at least
transiently, accumulation of
lipids that in part also
come from the lipolysis of
triglyceride stores in adipose tissue, feeding into this
ectopically accumulation of lipids in the liver.
And also reduced ketogenesis was described in the
liver that might overall contribute to a kind of a
deficiency of energy substrates systemically.
However, there were still open questions concerning the role of the liver in
cachexia, so we did a study where we
tried to further characterize hepatic dysfunction and the
contribution to weight loss in cachexia, and we focus on transcriptional
reprogramming, in particular in hepatocytes.
And this is published work, this is why I want to only go briefly through it.
So we did ATAC and RNA-Seq from hepatocytes and whole liver
tissue and integrated those data using machine learning to come up
with specific motives of transcription factors dysregulated in
cachexia. And there were the usual suspects, like
NF-kappa B, so downstream inflammatory system
signaling. But one thing that
we found pretty interesting was a severe
disruption of the molecular clock of the
liver,
and in particular, completely blunted REVERB expression,
which is a transcriptional repressor
of the molecular clock in the liver.
And this resulted in oversecretion of specific hepatokines
that then further also contributed to wasting by
specifically affecting the peripheral tissues, adipose tissue
and muscle. And when we
reconstituted REVERB expression in the liver, this had
an impact on weight loss. So we think there are
important tissue crosstalk mechanisms,
for instance, related to the loss of the molecular clock
in the liver that contribute to wasting.
But then, I would like to more extensively talk about one project
that goes back to this kind of tumor as the primary initiator of
wasting, and I want to give the credit to Giuliano, who did all the
work. And
we asked the question, so why are some tumors inducing cachexia, others not?
Are there more specific tumor-derived mediators to
discover? And there is a number of mediators that
have been described already.
And it's not always clear to which extent they come from the tumor and the
host. This is probably a mixture of things.
And this is why in the review, we described this as a gradient
with some factors being more clearly tumor derived and others
are
tumor as well as host derived or more host derived,
that then eventually affect all these processes that lead to wasting
in adipose tissue, like the lipolysis that I described and
muscle atrophy and other systemic consequences of
these tumor signals. But some years ago, we became
interested in one factor from the ADAMTS-like protein.
So these are secreted glycoproteins, and there's this ADAMTS-like 4.
The expression in the tumor was associated with increased mortality for different
cancer types that are also associated with cachexia.
So we looked into this factor,
which belongs to the ADAM family of metalloproteases but
lacks the catalytic domain, so there is no enzymatic
activity. So we looked into
thelevels of this
factor in different mouse models, and here are some of the main mouse
models that we use, the C26 mouse models, where colon cancer cells are
implanted subcutaneously, and this leads then to weight loss.
And as a comparison, we used
MC38-implanted mice,
also a colon cancer cell line that grows similar tumors but does not
induce cachexia. And when we compared the ADAMSLIK4 levels, there
was a clearly increase of ADAMSLIK4 in the cachexia condition,
but not in the MC38 or the PBS control mice.
And this was also true for another genetic model of colon cancer,
the APC model, where we have severe weight loss, and this was also
associated with increased circulating ADAMSLIK4 levels.
And similarly, in the LLC model, a lung cancer model
where LLC cells are subcutaneously implanted, also
here increased ADAMSLIK4. And when we
correlated over all these models ADAMSLIK4
levels with the relative body weight change, there was a significant
correlation indicating that there might be indeed a link
between ADAMSLIK4 and weight loss in these cachexia models.
Then we looked into
patient samples. Here, a colorectal cancer
cohort. Here you see the effect of cachexia.
So we stratified the patients for cachectic and non-cachectic patients.
And also here there was a significant difference in ADAMSLIK4
levels with cachexia
patients showing increased levels.
And when we then looked into the cachexia index
that takes weight loss as well as BMI under consideration, there
was also a correlation between ADAMSLIK4
circulating levels and the degree of cachexia based on this
cachexia
index. Then we had the chance to look into the TRACER X
data,
which are also part of the CanCan consortium studying cachexia
for lung cancer. Here you see the stratification for non-cachectic and
cachectic patients. And also here we see a correlation
or an induced levels of ADAMSLIK4 indicating that there might
indeed be a link between ADAMSLIK4 and cachexia.
And interestingly, in this cohort, we saw that
patients with high
circulating levels of ADAMSLIK4 had a
worse overall survival. And interestingly, this was not
true for disease-free survival, and we interpreted this in the
way that this effect might be due to cachexia and
not to cancer progression. And this is why we
decided also to then study this further mechanistically.
So the first thing we did, we overexpressed ADAMSLIK4 in these
non-cachexia inducing MC38 cells.
And here you see the induction of levels upon overexpression of
ADAMSLIK4 in MC38 cells. And interestingly, in
comparison to the parental cell line, which does not
induce cachexia, these cells now gained the
ability to induce cachexia. So they turned cachexigenic
by overexpressing ADAMSLIK4, and this was related
also to
loss in fat as well as lean body mass or muscle mass.
And there was also a significant decrease in cross-sectional area in
the muscle of these cells, and we saw also an effect on grip strength as a
functional readout of the muscle.
And then we did the
inverse experiment. We took this cachexia-inducing
C26 cells and knocked down ADAMSLIK4.
And then when you implant these cells, this resulted in reduced levels of
ADAMSLIK4 in the tumor as well as
circulation. It's not complete, but still, this was sufficient
to ameliorate weight loss in this model.
So knocking down ADAMSLIK4 reduced
the capacity of these cells to induce cachexia, further
confirming that this might be a real
mediator of the wasting process. Here, the
phenotypic characterization of the muscles.
There is the loss in lean mass. This was completely rescued
by knockdown of ADAMSLIK4
in the tumor. The same was true for the cross-sectional area, complete
rescue, and
interestingly also for adipose tissue.
You see the dramatic loss in adipose tissue, and this was
ameliorated
when we knocked down ADAMSLIK4 in the tumor.
And eventually, this also then prolonged
cachexia-free survival, here defined as the time point when
we have to kill the mice due to the humane endpoint of weight loss.
And this was strongly
prolonged upon knockdown of this factor.
Then we looked into the muscles to further characterize the molecular
characteristics. Here you see main E3 ligases that are an
important part of the atrophy process in the muscle.
They are induced in the cachectic condition.
When we knock down ADAMSLIK4 in the tumor, this was completely
rescued. And the same was true also for factors involved in the autophagy
process, another kind of process that is
important for the wasting of muscle.
And this was also reversed upon knockdown of ADAMSLIK4 in the
tumor. And eventually, here you see the
suppression of pathways that are
induced in cachexia like autophagy and proteasomal
degradation of proteins, and these were
completely suppressed upon knockdown of
ADAMSLIK4, showing that ADAMSLIK4
was connected to an overall atrophic process in the
muscle.So we asked how does this work and
can we characterize the mechanism?
So we took advantage of a technology called TRICEPS
to kind of
capture potential ligands for orphans.
Adamslike4 here is the ligand, is kind of
bound to this TRICEPS moiety, which
includes a cross-linking
part to cross-link with potential interactors on the cell
surface of living cells, as well as a biotin leg for
purification for further analysis by mass
spectrometry. And when we did this experiment, we
found pro-TGF beta as the main binding partner
of Adamslike4 on myotubes.
Here is shown the comparison to the positive control using
transferrin,
binding to the transferrin receptor.
We have this kind of similar data also for a negative control.
So this was a strong candidate, pro-TGF beta.
So what is pro-TGF beta? This is the precursor transcribed from one
gene,
which is then processed in the ER and contains
both the mature TGF beta growth factor as well as the
latency associated peptide. So they are from one gene, are processed, but
then stay together non-covalently bound and are transferred to the
plasma membrane,
where then TGF beta is stored in an inactive state and can be released
from this complex then to activate the receptor
and signal through the Smad signaling pathway.
So we thought, okay, maybe Adamslike4 might interact with this complex.
And the question was,
in which way? And for this we did immunoprecipitations where
we tried to kind of dissect whether
Adamslike4 is binding to TGF beta itself or
the LAP. And from this IP it was pretty clear that
Adamslike4 was binding to the LAP but not to TGF
beta itself. This we could confirm using
a split luciferase assay where we used LAP with a
large bead and Adamslike4 with a small bead of luciferase.
When you put it together, then you have luciferase when there
is an interaction, and this was exactly the case,
confirming the IP result
regarding the interaction of Adamslike4 with LAP.
And this was also true when we used the whole cell lysate.
And then if we do the assay similarly for TGF beta and LAP
as a kind of inactive complex, when you
put this together, then we have a signal.
If we add Adamslike4, then the
signal is reduced, indicating
that the interference of Adamslike4 with LAP was reducing the
interaction between TGF beta and LAP.
So we think this is the mechanism of action,
based on kind of an activation of TGF beta signaling.
And this we could also show here, for instance, concerning the release of
TGF beta upon treatment of myotubes with recombinant
Adamslike4.
TGF beta signaling results also in TGF beta expression.
See, this is what you see here. When we treat myotubes with Adamslike4,
TGF beta expression is induced. When we knock down TGF beta, this
effect is abolished. And interestingly, this is also reflected at the level of
myotube atrophy. This is the atrophy effect of the myotubes upon
treatment with recombinant Adamslike4.
This can be abolished upon knockdown of TGF beta.
And similarly, we can also rescue this effect by
small molecule inhibitors of the TGF beta receptor.
Here you see the induction of Smad2 signaling upon treatment of myotubes
with Adamslike4. This is completely abolished
upon inhibition of the
TGF beta receptor, and this is also reflected in the level
of atrogin-1 expression. So the atrophy
inducing factor, this expression is induced upon treatment with
Adamslike4 and also reduced upon inhibition of the
receptor. And this is also reflected in the phenotype
of the myotubes. So Adamslike4 treatment induces
myotube atrophy, and this can be counteracted by
inhibiting the TGF beta receptor.
Then we looked again into the
tissue from the mice. We see that upon knockdown
of Adamslike4 in the tumor,
induction of TGF beta target genes is strongly
reduced again in these livers. And interestingly, this is also associated
with effects on fibrosis. I mean, TGF beta is known as an important
factor for tissue fibrosis. We see muscle fibrosis in cachexia,
and this effect is ameliorated upon knockdown of
Adamslike4
in the tumor. We then confirmed this in
primary
myotubes from human. Again, the effect of Adamslike4
treatment to myotube atrophy can be abolished by
treatment with a neutralizing antibody against TGF beta,
and this is also reflected on the level of TGF beta
target genes.
Eventually, we had the chance to look into a subcohort of
colon and pancreatic cancer patients, where we see
again the induction of Adamslike4 related to
the cachexia phenotype. And also here we see
induced atrophy markers, TGF beta
target genes and
fibrosis related genes induced in the muscles of these
patients.
So, umI hope I could convince you that
this might be an interesting factor.
Circulating atoms like four levels are increased in cachexia and
contribute to muscle and adipose tissue loss, and this is mediated through
activation of TGF-beta signaling in the muscle.
And this is why we think, at least for those patients with induced
atoms like four levels, this might be an interesting target to
counteract cachexia by a novel pharmacotherapy.
And with this, I would like to end and acknowledge again Juliano, who did the
work. I realized I don't have a current picture from my group, so I generated
one. This is me, obviously, the older guy.
This is Juliano and the others in my group.
Thank you very much for your attention.
Great talk.
Thank you.
So I guess therapeutically, do you think there'd be any advantage in targeting the
atom protein you described versus just TGF-beta inhibition?
Sorry, can you-- Yeah. I get it. Yeah,
TGF-beta targeting is out there for some time, and to my
knowledge, there is no really
approved therapy, and this might be due to the pleiotropic
functions of TGF-beta. So my hope would be that
targeting atoms like four might be more specific to this cachexia
condition related to increased levels and
spare other TGF-beta dependent effects, and by this, be
a way to go. Yeah.
Really nice data. And Jessica Bauer from UCSD.
I have a question. Did you also look for other receptors of the
TGF-beta superfamily, like activin or BMPs, or?
Yeah, good question. In this TRICEPS
analysis, it was pretty clear, the target.
However, what we see, and I did not show the data, is, for instance, that
when you treat myotubes with atoms like four, we see induction of activin.
So there might be also a crosstalk to other kind of
atrophy-related processes, including maybe
a feed forward autocrine loop of activin then
activating the activin Type II receptor.
So, and this might then have an additional protective
effect if we counteract this.
Very beautiful work.
Thank you.
Could you expand a little more about what happens to the tumor when you
disrupt atoms like four?
Yeah. Obviously, we did not look into tumor microenvironment and
all the things that Min Lee is doing.
We don't see any effects on tumor growth.
So proliferation is similarly in vitro and tumor size in vivo is also
the same, but to be honest, we did not go beyond this.
So we see, okay, there is no effect on tumor growth, but we did
not further characterize if any other features of the tumor,
metabolic features, composition of the tumor is
affected by this knockdown. Thank you.
All right. Hello.
So,
I'm going to talk today about data that we've collected
from Kaiser Permanente's integrated healthcare system where I work.
And I'm going to argue that we, rather than a fixed
endpoint, can observe cachexia as a dynamic process
in patients with advanced cancer.
And in the second part of the talk, I'm going to introduce a prospective
study where we're collecting blood symptom data and asking whether
longitudinal phenotyping can drive us closer to
identifying targeted and early interventions that might slow or
reverse cachexia. So that's the goal.
The current consensus criteria established in 2011 outlines stages
of pre-cachexia beginning with symptoms and physiologic changes, followed by
clinically significant weight loss, and eventually progressing to a refractory
state where function really declines and survival is short.
So this is inherently dynamic. But in clinical research,
cachexia is much more typically operationalized as a static
5%
weight loss or greater over six months or less.
And once a patient has reached that threshold, they're sort of considered forever
cachectic in analyses.
As you heard earlier, our colleague at Memorial Sloan Kettering, Ed Resnick
has created some really useful codes that allow us to better
treat cachexia as dynamic using smooth BMI
trajectories that have these sort of sliding six-month windows.
And that lets us leverage the rich electronic data that are available
to us in our healthcare system to study this.
So when we implemented his approach in nearly 6,000 of our patients
with advanced lung, pancreatic, and colorectal cancer, what we found
is we do have some patients who are in consistent cachexia.
So that's illustrated here by this colorectal cancer patient.
Their cachectic episode begins before diagnosis, so that's the
dotted line vertically. They're still experiencing cachectic
loss when we see them at the baseline visit of our prospective study, that's the
green vertical line. And then you could see
as the
follow-up continues through one year, the red window widens, the blue
line continues to go deeper, and they're experiencing profound
and progressive weight loss.
This approach, though, also captures more dynamic versions of cachexia
cycles of decline and recovery. So here in blue, you have
patients who are actively in cachexia at
diagnosis and also when we saw them at our baseline visit,
but then they stabilize for a period of time before experiencing a
subsequent cachectic episode.And in the lung cancer patient there,
you can see that the measurements actually end shortly before their death, and
that's represented by the red line.
So then on the bottom panel, we do of course have patients, even pancreatic cancer
patients, who never experience cachectic weight loss over the period of time in
which we observe them. And so this has implications for studying the
underlying biology of cachexia in real world patients, because
now, thanks to Ed's codes, we can define clinical time points during
which patients were pre-cachectic, experiencing cachexia,
or perhaps they've recovered from a bout of weight loss,
and may reenter one. And so then we can really hone in on what is the period of
time clinically that we're interested in studying, and how does this align with
treatment trajectories and progression.
And so these are individuals, of course, that I've shown you.
What is happening at the population level?
How relevant are these different types when you zoom out?
And as we saw before, there's actually quite a large
prevalence of cachexia, but this is true even at the time of diagnosis.
So what we found when we applied this to all patients who met this criteria,
so receiving systemic therapy, but unresectable pancreatic,
colorectal, or lung cancer over the last 10 years in our health system,
what we found is that the vast majority of pancreatic cancer patients, and actually
most colorectal patients as well, are already in
a cachectic episode that exceeds this 5% threshold
when they're diagnosed. In fact, for GI cancer, perhaps that's part of how
their diagnosis was precipitated.
So they're already in this experience, and the proportion is quite
high. But at the same time, a substantial proportion of
patients move in and out of this weight loss state over time.
And so what you're seeing at the right is that half of the colorectal cancer
patients who were cachectic at the time of their diagnosis,
they later stabilize or recover, suggesting that indeed the
cachexia can be slowed or reversed, and that this is true actually even
in a third of the pancreatic cancer patients in our system.
That's the stack bar on the far right.
But cachexia remains an ongoing threat, of course, because we have more than a
third of the colorectal and lung cancer patients who survive to
experience a new episode. So either they reenter
cachexia after a period of stabilization, or they recover,
or they develop it for the first time if they weren't experiencing cachectic weight
loss at diagnosis.
So the next thing we did is we took this dynamic framework, and then we
used CT imaging collected in the course of clinical care to
examine body composition changes during these episodes of cachectic weight
loss. And we used hierarchical clustering to find
different phenotypes of body composition change.
And what we see is that the first cluster in light blue, it's marked
by this denser Hounsfield unit radiodensity of adipose tissue,
and maybe that's an adaptive early change tissue
remodeling prior to the real
catabolic muscle and adipose tissue loss that you see
in, for example, group four, which has a lot of dark blue
indicating a lot of loss of skeletal muscle and adipose tissue,
or the moderate wasting group, where there's also more blue.
But we also have this group in the middle, the green splenomegaly group, where
they're experiencing increases in spleen volume and reductions
in the spleen density, and that's consistent maybe with a host
immune and inflammatory response.
And when we looked at these clusters biochemically, we did see that these three
bolded clusters in the middle have higher levels of active
NA, GDF15, IL6 and 8 compared to the
other groups. Although all five of these groups are experiencing cachectic weight
loss, they get kicked into the cachexia bucket, but they look
different biochemically, and they look different in terms of their body composition
change.
So the survival curves really mirror the biochemical findings in that
the folks with severe and moderate wasting, as well as the splenomegaly group, have
the shortest survival. So the wasting groups are the orange and purple lines at the
bottom, splenomegaly is the green.
And these risky phenotypes are more common in the pancreatic
cancer patients. That's the stack bar on the far right.
But you can see all the colors are represented in all of the cancer sites, so it's
not really driven by a single cancer type.
The other thing I want to note here, though, is that we derived these based on
patients that were already losing weight, that were in a bout or episode of
cachexia. We then applied these to patients who were weight stable, who
wouldn't be detected as at risk. And we found that a
quarter of the weight stable patients actually fit into these
three red boxed groups, these three risky groups with poor
survival. Even though they were weight stable, their body composition change
told a different story. And so that means that maybe we can use imaging to uncover
cachectic risk that might be missed if we wait too long for
clinical weight loss. So what I take from this is that
cachexia is not a static condition.
It's an evolving heterogeneous process, and
perhaps we can move beyond weight loss only
screening and identify patients earlier when supportive
or targeted interventions might be more successful.
That's the dream, and it brings us to the next question, which is
how can the longitudinal phenotyping that we're doing in our prospective study
inform what are the intervention targets that might slow or reverse
cachexia? Or what we're doing to begin with is trying to
find early biobehavioral signals
that precede future weight loss.
And so that's what we're tackling in our prospective study as part of the grand
challenges, and I'll spend the next part of the talk introducing that
study and sharing some of the very preliminary
findings.So as part of the grand challenges,
we have two sites with the same protocol and really different strengths.
So the site on the right, the Lotus study, that is based in the National
Community Oncology Research Program. So they have national reach.
They're recruiting from the states shown in blue there, whereas our site,
UNCOVER, is based only within the Kaiser Permanente Northern California system.
But we have some key advantages in that we can phenotype all 4.6
million patients that we serve, and we know who we haven't recruited
as well as who we have, and we can characterize everyone
before diagnosis as well as track their entire treatment
experience.
So both of these studies are recruiting patients with a primary diagnosis of
unresectable lung, pancreatic, or colorectal cancer who are beginning
first-line therapy in the next six weeks.
And
ultimately, the hope is to recruit around 1,600
patients into the observational study.
We've recruited across the two sites well over 900
now. About half of them have non-small cell lung cancer, and we
already have good representation across racial and ethnic groups.
And it's not shown here, but these are real-world patients in the sense that
many of them have multiple non-cancer comorbid conditions coming
into their diagnosis. So complex to study, but perhaps more relevant
to the patient experience.
We have active data collection at two time points.
We're considering adding a third.
And during the active data collection at the baseline visit within six weeks of
therapy, we collect blood, which we are now testing
for a variety of markers related to inflammation, stress, and
metabolism. We also collect patient-reported questionnaires that
cover anorexia and cachexia, as well as pain, sleep,
emotional and physical wellbeing, appetite.
And then we're also doing functional testing, so the time to get up and
go and some other tests, as well as hip-worn accelerometry
for a week each visit in order to capture these sort of
24-hour activity patterns in this highly sedentary
population, which is in itself, I think, a challenge.
And then we repeat that same protocol at the three-month visit.
So again, we have the advantage of the comprehensive medical record,
so we can do passive data collection out to one year and beyond.
So for that, we're mining the record for lab values, tumor markers,
clinical histories, but also outcomes that might be harder to collect in an
active contact study, like toxicity, hospitalization, and progression on therapy.
And then, of course, we're segmenting the clinical images, the CT images for body
composition at the time points shown there.
So now what we've done is we're starting to dig into these data a little bit
and try to understand them, and again, try to phenotype patients
experiencing weight loss. So our first pass at that was to
take the questionnaire, physical function assessment, and
laboratory values that were available to us at the time and to conduct some
variable selection and put these into a latent class analysis.
And this very early pass resulted in two
classes, a red class shown there and an orange class shown there.
But as we collect more data, as we assay more detailed and cachexia-relevant
biomarkers, our hope is to either see if these
clusters are stable, to enhance the clusters
and see what other variables define them, as well as to predict them.
So for now, what we're finding is two distinct weight loss phenotypes, and
they're really defined. We're calling them the high symptom burden, that's the red,
or the low symptom burden, that's sort of the orangey-yellow.
And the red symptom burden group's really distinguished by very high
rates of fatigue, depression, poor physical wellbeing, and high
nutritional risk. Whereas the orange lower symptom burden group,
they appear better than even the green comparator patients who are not
experiencing cachectic weight loss on the measurements here.
Very little fatigue, almost no depression or anxiety, and
then rates of physical wellbeing and nutritional risk that
are the same or lower than the comparator group.
So additionally, on the right there, I'm just showing that again, pancreatic cancer
patients are overrepresented in the cachectic clusters, but they occur
across the three groups. So this is not a single cancer site
phenomenon.
So aside from very low self-reported physical activity, that's at the
bottom there. So you can see that both the red and the orange group have higher
rates of low activity as compared to the non-cachectic folks.
The orange group looks better even than the control on
every patient-reported outcome, whereas the red group, the
high symptom burden group, you can see they look quite a bit worse than
the control that's not losing weight.
So anorexia and cachexia symptoms are 39% higher
abnormal rates in the high symptom burden group.
When you move on to looking at these groups biochemically, what you can see
is that both cachexia groups have a high prevalence of abnormal liver markers,
elevated cortisol and leptin.
Sorry, low leptin, low albumin, and lower HDL-C,
so kind of the profile you might expect with weight loss.
But when you zoom in on the stress and inflammation markers,
it's really clear, I think, that the high symptom burden group
in red has much profoundly higher levels of
these more cachexia-relevant markers than does the low symptom
burden group.
So perhaps it's these mediators that in part are associated with or
drive the symptom burden or can at least predict it.
So this is prognostic as well. Despite
having similar weight loss at baseline in the low symptom
group, the high symptom group in red goes on to lose more
weight a lot faster and to have lower survival.
So that's distinct from the lower symptom burden group in the yellowy orange
that really can't be distinguished from the green no active cachexia baseline
group for quite a long time, almost 10 or 12 months into
follow-up.What we don't know, though, is are these
different stages of cachexia, are these symptoms
early signals that truly identified patients that might benefit from
specific interventions or specific timing of intervention?
And we're hoping to learn that in partnership with our pre-clinical colleagues as
part of the grand challenge.
So to wrap up,
cachexia is a dynamic and potentially reversible process.
When we move beyond this kind of static 5% weight loss cutoff,
we find discrete episodes of cachectic weight loss that
resolve,
and they also recur, and that can allow us to better
study different subtypes and hone in on the right time period in the
clinical timeline. When we do that, we see that we have
clusters of patients that are distinguished by body composition as well as
symptoms, and that parses groups with differing rates of future
weight loss as well as differing survival, and to some
extent, differing biochemical profiles.
And then importantly, you find these clusters even in patients who are not
yet losing weight.
Finally, I hope you've been introduced to the large prospective study that we're
assembling that we hope will provide a new longitudinal
resource to find these subtypes and
work towards early models of prediction of cachexia.
So this is obviously a team effort, so I want to thank my co-lead
at my site, Betty Kahn, as well as the CanKen leadership.
And then I have a shameless plug. If you want to talk more about this, I will be
babysitting my post-doc Anlin Cao's poster on Wednesday
morning, and so we can talk both about cachexia as well as about how visceral
adiposity and age shape the tumor microenvironment in non-metastatic
breast cancer. So thank you very much.
Hi. Really fantastic talk. I have two questions that are
somewhat related maybe. One is you kind
of distinguish between these five
clusters that cachectic patients go through.
So I'm just wondering, is the idea that it's always dynamic that patients
are going to undergo moderate wasting and severe
wasting and/or splenomegaly at some point,
or can it be static and it varies between the patients?
And also my second question is basically,
are these clusters mutually exclusive?
So can a patient have splenomegaly and also severe wasting?
Yes.
So, first of all, I want to say we're early in this, so we haven't
completed all of the detailed analyses that we wish to do.
But we do see overlap between-- If you imagine the heat
map, there were patients in what we called the
splenomegaly group who were experiencing wasting
and also getting bigger livers or smaller
livers. So there was a lot of heterogeneity in that group.
The boundaries are not distinct, and there's lots of other ways, I think, to look
at those data. I think the earlier part of your question was driving at,
do patients, as they experience recurrent weight loss, cycle in and
out of these phenotypes? And I don't have a good answer to that yet, but we are
collecting the data to do that. We started with just
looking at change between two time points because
we're still segmenting the scans and quality controlling them.
But the hope is that we'll have repeated episodes and
repeated scans so that we can answer that question of, what does the
rebound look like? It's probably not till baseline.
Really impressive talk.
Amazing number of data points that you have.
I was trying to understand
when you showed us the
different groups, so patients that have stress, anxiety,
can you uncouple that from the weight loss?
So when you showed the survival curve, those patients had
the anxiety, the stress, the weight loss, but we already know that weight loss will
predict survival. So
is that possible to uncouple that so we're just looking at those
phenotypes without the weight loss-
Yeah
... to see if that's sufficient to drive the difference in survival?
That's a great question.
Does that question make sense?
I think so.
Yeah.
I can tell you how we've tried to evaluate that because we've thought about that.
One is,
unlike in a pre-clinical model where you know exactly when cancer initiation is,
we're seeing patients at diagnosis, which is variable time points
from cancer initiation, and many patients, as you know, have experienced weight
loss prior to their diagnosis, right?
So
our approach has been is we want to catch you in the red window, and we can tell
that, but how deep you are into that window is going to vary
on the individual level. So what I was worried about is, is the higher symptom
group just people who have lost more weight who have been in the red window longer?
And the answer is actually no. The duration of exposure to
cachectic weight loss, how deep are you in the red, is very similar.
Both the achieved weight loss and the weeks of exposure to weight loss are
very similar between the high and the low symptom burden groups, and yet their
destinies differ. So the red group loses more weight after that
baseline visit where we're measuring their symptoms
than the orange group.
So I think that what that tells us is there's an uncoupling then of the
weight loss that you've experienced until the time of that symptom assessment and
then where you go next. The red group loses weight faster and has shorter
survival. The orange group has much longer survival, and they lose weight,
but at a much slower pace thereafter. So I thought that was profound.
The other way we've tried to measure it is just simply doing some Cox modeling
where we try to look at how the symptoms predict survival and
subsequent weight loss,
controlling for the weight loss that's been achieved, so similar.
And again, the symptoms really do tell you who's at risk.
So turns out asking people how they feel is a powerful tool, which I
think many oncologists would tell you.
Great. Thank you.
Hi. I think you showed that patients with cachexia have low levels of
HDL or can have lower levels. So does that mean that
patients with dyslipidemia are more at risk for cachexia?
I don't know the answer to that question, but I think it's a good one.
Maybe you should ask it again in the panel.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you very much. I just want to congratulate all the people who've gone
before me. I've recently introduced Mike Wickler at the in-house
seminar in Cold Spring Harbor, and he made an important point that the best
scientists are those who have imagination
and who are rigorous, and of course, you know that those two things are slightly at
odds. But I hope you've seen that as
this sort of field of cachexia is growing, there's a real
opportunity to have imagination because it touches on
so many aspects, and if you then study it rigorously, it takes you down so
many potential avenues of not only understanding a condition that
affects many patients, but also on understanding fundamental
principles of biology that are transferable to so many other conditions even
beyond cancer. And, as such, I would like to
invite all of you to think about studying the whole body response to
cancer and thereby contributing to this field that is growing of
understanding the biology of the human
condition.
I have no disclosures. I
want to follow on from what we've heard before.
It's easy to think about cachexia as a systemic disease from
tumor-mediated factors, and that's what we also do in our lab.
We are thinking about what cells within the microenvironment make which factors
that radiate out into the system, and which parts of the organ
orchestration can be affected through these factors, and then how do these networks
interact. And I've got a terrific team making contributions for it.
And I actually have also a terrific team represented here in
the audience, and I'm giving a shout-out here for their posters.
Go and see them and speak to them about their findings.
Amanda has a great set of results relating to how the tumor can be
targeted without affecting the host with a creative new idea.
Tubha has some great data showing how
hypercalcemia can drive terminal cardiac dysfunction and contribute to the
actual mechanism of death from cachexia.
And Alice has spent several years now studying healing from
cachexia and what molecular drivers might
enable recovery as organisms
come through the process of cachexia, and please visit their posters and have a
look at it.
I want to take a step back from the perspective of cachexia to say,
okay, what are the potential evolutionary underlying principles as
the whole organism responds to a perturbation response?
And I want
you to think about two potential scenarios.
One is that a tumor is immunogenic and the immune response is
sufficient to eliminate the tumor even very early on, and so the organism
goes through this transient state before then completely recovers, but
maybe have a small demarcation of having been exposed to a cancer, maybe even
unbeknown to the organism. And then there is a second scenario where
the initial activation of the immune system is insufficient, and a
chronic inflammation occurs and drives
progression of the organism ultimately to dying, and this is probably what
we call cancer-associated cachexia.
And I've split my talk into two sections here.
I'm trying to get you to understand that these two scenarios are not at
odds, but that they are actually having a unifying process, and I want you
to think about cachexia more in the context of paraneoplasia as
a whole as I go through these two examples.
And for the first example, I'd like you to think about what might be the
antigens here. You hear a lot about neoantigens in different talks at AACR,
and I'm not disputing that they are relevant, but there's also through
transcription of dysregulations in cancer cells, the expression of non-mutant self
that can be immunogenic, including onco-neural antigens.
And the first paraneoplasia study that I want you to think about is related
to that.
Specifically, if you look into tumors of patients with cancer, these are
patients with triple-negative breast cancer, and look at their expression
profiling by RNA-seq or protein expression, you see expression of
onco-neural antigens. In particular,
for example, here gene expression in cancer cells of-- I don't
know, can you-- Oh, yeah, you see the marker.
Of
genes that drive subunit productions of NMDA receptors.
That's a heterotetrameric
neurotransmitter receptor that is usually expressed in the brain exclusively and in
the developing brain. And actually, this subunit, GRIN2B, is one of the
subunits that's really only expressed during development.
In other words, it's not expressed in the adult organism, and it's also not
expressed in the thymus, so there's no priming for adaptive immunity to
this subunit. You can see that we can see this by RNA and by protein
expression, as you can see here within the tumors.
That can be immunogenic. And for example, you can follow titers of
antibodies against these proteins in patients with triple-negative breast cancer
and detect that they are elevated in the cohort of
cancer patients. Even in the healthy controls, we occasionally see some antibodies
against these proteins. And you can see that the expression of high
antibodies actually demarcates better outcome for these patients.
And again, when you look in the tumors, you can see there's protein expression in
the tumor of these patients that have the antibodies.
This is from the tumor of the patient who has the highest titer of the antibodies.
So we built a system to try and understand
the etiology of this, and essentially what we made is an expression
system in the mouse where we could hyper-express this
receptor, and then a decoy system for the receptor to pull out B
cells that were reactive with it. AndOnce we
sequence those B cell populations, we can reconstruct the
phylogeny of the antibodies that are expressed in these B cells, and I'm showing
you the results from that experiment here.
So here are four antibody phylogenies of antibody
families that we've extracted from these tumors of mice that
hyper-express GluN1, GluN2B heterotetramers of NMDA
receptor. And you can see that we can trace these families back and actually
trace them back so well that we can impute the unmutated
common ancestor of these antibodies.
So in other words, the antibody that is germline encoded and hasn't
hypermutated and affinity matured.
And then we can express the antibodies and find out what happens
when these antibodies bind the receptor.
And this is a movie that shows you that as the antibody binds
the receptor, which is resolved through cryo-EM,
it pulls the receptor into a different constellation.
So it works like an allosteric regulator.
These two alpha helices that are approximated here, I'll show you the movie again,
they are actually gating helices for the membrane
channel, and
we know that by approximating these alpha helices, these
receptors get put into a conformation that allows higher calcium
influx. So we now have a structure function relationship from these
antibodies that come from tumors that ectopically
express non-mutant self,
to change these receptors in their structure function.
And
so what we did next is we asked, does that really have an
influence on the activation pattern of these channels?
And for that, we did an electrophysiological experiment where we overexpressed the
receptors in Xenopus oocytes, together with the Furukawa lab, who
are the drivers for the structural biology as well, and really world-class
experts. And this experiment was done by Reuven, a postdoc in his lab,
where we overexpress this receptor in oocytes, then give the agonist
and then the antibody, and then find out what happens to the activation pattern of
these receptors. And as you can see here, in the presence
of the normal agonist, these
receptors get opened, and this is the ion flux across this.
And then in a dose-dependent manner, as we wash in the receptor, we see activation
of these end receptors. So in other words, there's true demonstration that these
antibodies can allosterically regulate the receptor.
And then we ask, can that change behavior?
And the way by which we did that is we infused the receptor into the left
ventricle of mice and ask what changes in terms of their autonomic stability
and seizure threshold and their activation pattern.
I'm showing you the seizure data here.
These mice, as we expose them to induction
of seizures with a GABA receptor antagonist that doesn't
cause seizures at that level in controls, have massive
upregulation of seizure activity.
So in other words, there's a structure function relationship that is
engendered by antibodies that are derived from a tumor that goes down to
the whole body effect
of the organism. And so this is the entirety of
this sequence. It's just come out in publication, so please read up on the
details and give us feedback.
And essentially what we are showing is that there's a germline predisposition for
this immune activation that can ultimately lead to behavioral
changes. Sort of to put this into a single sentence,
behavioral changes, potentially even psychotic episodes, can
be the consequence of the cancer that you never knew you had.
And so that sort of follows a principle axis that we
use to think about the whole body response on paraneoplasia in the lab,
that you get a release from a cellular structure,
which can be a tumor, of substances that enter the
circulation, then bind specific receptors, and thereby change
the function of the cells that express the receptor and the function of the
organ and ultimately the organism.
And I've just shown you that in this paraneoplastic syndrome related to NMDA
receptors, that can be the case. And we've heard already before that this might
also be happening in cancer-associated cachexia.
So this is a sort of conceptional framework that I think lends itself to
understanding
specific reprogramming mediated by circulating
molecules in the organism. And
so I've shown you how this is relevant to this first part,
an induction of a response, and then the healing.
And I want to summarize on a single slide how this relates to the second part,
because that's now been published and is a bit longer, and I presented it at AACR
last year in detail. What we have shown is that
these molecules that leave the tumor, if you focus on this
neurone side of the diagram, they can enter the
circulation and ligate receptors in the area postrema and
then signal forward into the brain, into the nucleus accumbens, to
quantitatively downregulate dopamine, which is the main
neurotransmitter that drives volitional behavior, and
the absence of it can cause apathy.
And the apathy itself can then cause underperformance in foraging tasks
in animals, and therefore hypophagia, contributing to the
negative energy balance that drives cachexia.
Because if you think about cachexia just purely as a wasting syndrome, it is
obvious that there must be a negative energy balance because otherwise the wasting
wouldn't occur. And one of the open questions, I think, in the field is still to
what degree is the wasting driven by reduced energy intake or
by increased energy expenditure or a bit of both, and probably that's
context dependent. Currently, my feeling is that it's
predominantly reduced energy intake, but that's influenced, of
course, by the bias of me looking at model systems and data that seem to
suggest that. I'm not saying that's the universal answer.
It's interesting to think about this network and this circuit of sickness more
generally. You can imagine that this is driven in other conditions
that are cachexia associated. If you've had a viral disease, this circuit might
well be activated, and you've gone through a mini cachexia during,
say, flu. Or if you had tuberculosis, which
is-Subacutely lingering in your lungs and
causes consumption, and that circuit might well be activated.
But also, Jiling Shen is in the audience, he published with
Eilat Res a nice paper showing that vagal inputs can actually also feed
into this system. And so it's interesting to see how systemic sensing, not
just in the context of released factors, but also activation
of the nervous system, can also actually signal into these brain
circuits and engender sickness behavior.
And Thalis Papagiannopoulos has also a paper in
revision at the moment to show that this vagal input into the brain can
also be relevant. So look out for those sort of different input circuits.
I think it's interesting, especially thinking about Elizabeth's wonderful work,
how patient-derived questionnaires can really guide us here,
because patients, as you can appreciate, when you ask
them precise questions, give you precise answers, and you have
quantitative data suddenly from patients that can drive your
research process. And with Elizabeth, we think a lot about
this in detail, and Eileen, who's also in the audience, and the CanCan team and the
broader community are exploring, I think, very
carefully, where are the dimensions of the systemic effects.
And we have some interesting data related to sleep again,
and that Alice is coordinating and driving at the moment, and to
other aspects of this psychological
dimensions of cancer-associated cachexia.
So I've taken you through these two scenarios, which are
potentially seemingly distinct from the first on look, where a
patient first gets transient inflammation and then heals
because the underlying condition is resolved, or where
this inflammation progresses and then causes systemic unwellness.
So one of the questions is, can those two be unified?
And in order to think about this more carefully, I paired up
with a really brilliant mathematician called David McCandless, who's at Cold Spring
Harbor Laboratory, who understood these axiomatic statements that I made.
And together we wrote a set of differential equations that we refined
that capture this in the context of dynamic systems theory.
So this is a theory that is used to test stability of systems in
engineering or other contexts, for example, bridge building
or
high skyscraper buildings or something like that.
And so these put into relation inflammation and
weight in a dynamic way, and they
can capture different scenarios.
For example, this sudden onset inflammation that resolves
with a transient weight loss here, or a second scenario where
this slowly increasing systematic
inflammation occurs, as we would see it in cancer progression and cachexia.
And you get this pseudo-stable weight trajectory here, and then
this rapid collapse once a threshold is
overcome that indicates terminal cachexia.
And I think it's important to note here that if you look at the levels
of inflammation in these
modeled systems, the
acute inflammation is actually acutely higher than the
inflammation that we ever get to. So it can be really this
subacute chronic inflammation that drives this systemic
collapse that Min Lee introduced at the very beginning of
this session. And so have a look at this in a
more detailed manner here in this
flow field and where we actually map out
inflammation and weight loss, and we can
look at the dynamics as they occur, as the basal
inflammation increases. And I will show you this by movie in a
second, but have a look at the homeostatic set point and the saddle point here.
These are the two stable points of this dynamic set of systems.
And as the basal inflammation increases, you will see how these
approximate each other. And this left side of the diagram here,
where the
unacute inflammation, a subtle weight loss occurs,
and then the system recurs to the homeostatic set point, becomes smaller and
smaller. And this right side, where the degree of inflammation
and weight loss is so severe that the system goes to terminal weight
loss or death or terminal cachexia, becomes bigger and bigger.
Have a look as we go through this. You can see how this
field develops more and more,
and you can see how these points approximate each other until they meet in
this saddle node bifurcation and annihilate each other, and the system
goes to this
terminal cachexia point. And if you think about this from a
systemic point of view and from the model systems and the patients that we've
heard of, this separatrix, this line here, and the saddle node
bifurcation, as this occurs,
that's essentially what in the clinical setting we would call
terminal cachexia. And so the saddle node bifurcation in the mathematical
model captures that specific moment,
the point of no return of the terminal cachexia.
So can we use this to understand the system better?
In order to do that, we did some experiments to see if the predictions from these
mathematical models hold up. So this is the predicted
relationship of inflammation and weight loss from this mathematical
model, and these are the measured data of body weight to
inflammation. And you could say, well, that's sort of unsurprising
because your very first information of how you build these
systems, the dynamic systems, was axiomatically driven by you
having a detailed understanding of the condition on the mouse model.
So the real acid test here, if you wish, is can this system make
predictions about perturbation responses that the
mathematical model hasn't seen before?
And so in order to do that, we actually did an experiment where we
temporarilyAnd food restrict these mice.
So we really drive for short periods of absolute energy deficiency,
total food restriction, TFR here, in early, intermediate, and late
stages of the
mouse model system. And then we ask,
do the predictions hold up against the measured data?
And if you look at this here, this is the mathematical prediction from this.
So the model makes three specific predictions.
One is the degree of total weight loss.
If you induce and this temporary caloric restriction
is not very different or is almost the same,
independent on the pseudo time progression of the model system.
However, if you look at this right side of the recovery
of the system, you can see that the slope decreases
and that the recovery becomes increasingly erratic during
progression.
And so in the end, some mice or some of the model systems would
not recover. And so then we do an experiment to see if that actually
holds up. And you can see here that the measured data actually show
what the model predicts. So in other words, we now have
the same phenomena that the degree of weight loss is almost
identical, and that as the mice progress from
early to late stages of cancer progression,
the difference is mostly apparent in this
recovery slope and the percentage recovery of the
mice, as you can see here in the summary data.
So we now have a theoretical framework to make predictions about
the response of our model system that we can then test experimentally, which
is a sort of context that I'm excited about because obviously, as you
all know, mostly we use mathematical approaches and data
analysis to make sense of data that we have acquired, but this is actually
a paradigm where we can make predictions and then test against those predictions.
So these are the contributions that we've made that
I've summarized in this talk. I think we have now emerging
evidence that this anticancer immunity and autoimmunity are on the same spectrum,
and as a consequence, that autoimmunity can be the consequence of the cancer
that you never knew you had. And the effect by which this autoimmunity
declares itself can be very profound and can really be
changed brain function and
behavior as a consequence.
We see that there is a continuity here, that
this temporary inflammation, when it's not
resolving, actually leads to
progressive reprogramming of the host organism and then to cachexia, and
I think that's one of the open questions in the field, if you so wish.
What can we learn from cachexia about normal biology? Why has this evolved?
Is cachexia actually not maladaptive, but is
it unsustainable but adaptive?
I hope you see the difference between the two processes.
And again, if I
may take the liberty as the chair of the session, I would like to
suggest that it's probably the latter.
In other words, it's not a pathological process.
It is a biological process that over time becomes
unsustainable for the organism. And I'm not the first one to express this
idea, but that's where I would be leaning, rather than it saying it's
a completely dysregulated nonsense process that just drives
random disease. And then, the other contribution is that I think we are
beginning to understand how these systems interact sufficiently
deeply now to make real theoretical frameworks
available to reason about the whole body response to cancer, and those
frameworks are hopefully
transferable well beyond the acute
context of cancer-associated cachexia.
I want to thank all of the supporters and all of the funding that we have received.
In particular, I want to give a shout-out for the Cancer Grand
Challenges,
who had the wisdom to
announce a cancer cachexia grand challenge, a good number of
years ago, and Eileen, Marcus, and I had the good fortune to be
successful with our bid for it. But I also want to say that the
community is really making a great effort jointly.
There are other focused efforts for cancer-associated
cachexia and societies like the Cancer Cachexia Society, and if you're interested
in coming into this field, keep an open mind how you reach out, and hopefully you
will find that we are all pulling in the same direction anyhow.
And so your entry port into this area of research can be through
various avenues,
as we hope that you join the team. And if you're really interested in this,
please consider to register for this wonderful
conference that we are organizing through the Cancer Grand
Challenges, where we are thinking about the host response to
cancer more broadly, not just cachexia.
And submit your thoughts and come
to join us to think about it, and I'm particularly thinking about Jose
and Stuart because it's in your neighborhood in London.
So please,
generate interest and send your application,
and I promise we'll find you a place and your lab members, and we'll hope to see
many of you there
in June. And with that, I think I'll take a few questions.
And I think those of you who are then interested in further discussions should hang
back a little bit, and I think we have the panel members stay back as well
so that you can have individual discussions, but because of time, I don't think we
should have a panel discussion at the end.
So anybody who wants to speak to any of the speakers, please line up
orderly on the side, and we will get to all of you because we've got ample of time
to go through all the questions that might remain. Thank you very much.
Tobias, thank you for the very thought-provoking talk, and it's
great. I have two questions. First, actually, about second part.
And I was a system biologist before, so really, really
appreciate the insight. If you talk to
clinicians, usually they say, "Oh, it's about reducing a tumor burden.
If you reduce a tumor burden, you're going to get better." So you are assuming this
kind of more linear relationship between tumor burden and the
cachexia. And here what you're saying is, if you're going through that path of no
return, it's not going to have that linear relationship
So my question is, if we're thinking about trying to revert that
condition, is it almost like a bistability?
It means
it's not just going back to the original level, then it's going to revert.
You almost have to do more to kind of try to pull it back, right?
If you think about a positive feedback, almost, the threshold is different if you
try to revert that condition. I'm just trying to see that.
Yeah. So those are
many questions, and I
appreciate your reasoning about them, and we think about, I think all of
us think about those questions
for many hours a day. I want to go systematically.
Firstly, the uncoupling of the tumor burden from the host response.
I think that I want to say two things about that.
It is more likely that as your cancer progresses and your tumor burden increases,
that you have systemic effects. I'm not disputing that.
Is it an absolute linear relationship? No.
We have clear evidence to the contrary that some people have massive tumor
burden and don't have any systemic effects, and some people have tiny tumors, as
far as we know, and have systemic effects.
In the clinic and also actually in neuro model systems, we sometimes see
complete uncoupling.
Tumors get bigger, mice get better, or vice versa.
So there's no definitive relationship.
But in first approximation, I think it holds true, and that gets me to the second
point, is what we are doing actually ultimately a standalone
effort, or should it be in the context of treating the cancer?
And I think all of us would agree that ultimately, of course, the elephant in the
room is to cure the cancer if we can,
because that will also, in no small parts, cure the organism.
The important bit here to think about is many patients who have cancer
progression, have systemic symptoms, are not well enough to get the systemic
treatments that we want to give them to cure the cancer.
And so I think one of the things by which we can reason about the whole body
response to cancer and what to do about it is through the therapeutic window.
So can we enable patients to be well enough to get all these
wonderful treatments that are being developed to push back against the cancer?
But I think it's a joint effort. Does that make sense?
Yes.
And then the question of hysteresis is an interesting question, and I have many
thoughts on that. And actually, you should speak to Alice, who's sitting in the row
behind you, because she's inadvertently done experiments about that,
and she sees that there is hysteresis in the system.
So in other words, if systems, at least model systems, develop
cachexia again, they develop it with a different dynamic than they did in
the first instance.
And then secondly, a quick question.
The first part of story, again, the beautiful nature paper on-- It's
puzzling that breast cancer is expressing those
embryonic
neural factors and that trigger that response.
Is
there a specific reason that breast cancer do that?
Or you think it's just a breast cancer turning on these fetal programs, and this is
just kind of byproduct of the breast cancer try to do EMT or the
breast cancer try to be more proliferative?
Yeah. Thank you for that question.
At the risk, again, of being slightly controversial, especially in the
context of AACR, I think about this disease site-agnostic.
I don't think this is restricted to breast cancer, to be absolutely clear.
Mm-hmm.
It is interesting to see, there is a very good paper from Jessica
Tolkun a couple of years back that ER is
one of the regulators for GluN2B
expression. So there might be a hormonal component, and so it might be
particularly predominant in patients with
triple-negative breast cancer. But again, I think this is
probably-- NMDA receptors get expressed in a multiplicity of cancers, and
it's only one example of an onco-neuroantigens. There are others.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Okay, I'll take two more questions.
Hi, I really enjoyed this session and understanding
more about the biology of cachexia.
Can you or any of the other speakers speak to how is this
biology going to translate into an intervention to try
to improve the cachexia and the quality of life and the
ability, as you said, to do stuff, whether it's
getting additional treatment or being able to just function in your life?
What do you see for the future there?
Thank you for asking that question because Min already
gave an honorary mention to one of the front-running ideas,
GDF15 blockade, which did not really feature in the session today, but
not because we don't think it's important, but it's featuring broadly across
the conference and other contexts.
So the answer is, as we understand those molecular pathways that really
drive the defining features, say, the negative
energy balance through reduced food intake, and GDF15 is one of those
hormones that signals to the brain to drive food aversion and negative energy
balance. They can be blocked, and others, not myself, and to my
knowledge, none of the speakers in this session have made contributions to
understanding that specifically, and there are clinical trials now.
A phase II trial was reported where GDF15
signaling to the brain is blocked in those patients who have high
GDF15, and there are suggestions that the outcome is better
based on
muscle mass, if I remember correctly, mostly than
any other feature so far. And so there are continuation studies of this.
And so again, I think this is now moving into the clinic,
but one of the things that we really have to do is to understand is this one
condition or is this several conditions that converge on the
same terminal appearance? And
then how can we parse those conditions out into understanding molecular mechanisms
that can be targeted?
Thank you. Final question.
Yeah. En Cheng from Albert Einstein College of Medicine.
I think this seminar is really eye-opening.
I really appreciate every investigator show their
cutting-edge results. I want to ask a follow-up question
followed by Jenny. I think the New England Journal of
Medicine last year, they published a trial, penciclib,
which is quite promising to counter cachexia.
How do you see this may impact the field, like everyone right now
is investigating? And the second question, I really like the
mathematic formulas showing inflammation scores, et
cetera. I'm very curious how possible it can be
translated into a clinical use. For example, we have the
whole blood count test, and we can use an LRO, maybe
some more easily
to assess inflammation. I'm curious, what's the next step?
Okay, thank you. I will not answer the first question because we've just discussed
it, but thank you for pointing it out again.
The panzochrom map studies are interesting and people should read up on those, and
they are biomarker driven and mechanistically explained, so it's robust work.
Please inform yourself about it. I want to talk about the second question, to what
degree can we understand the system through mathematical
equations, and how can that be moved into the clinic?
And one thing that is very interesting for people to think about, many
clinicians, endocrinologists, cardiologists, respiratory physicians,
challenge the organism, in other words, the patient, when they try to make
diagnoses and try to understand where the patient is on the
personal trajectory of disease progression.
That's standard practice in multiplicities
of clinical practice. It's not standard practice
in oncology other than for the fact that we inadvertently challenge the
patient with the treatments that we give them, which have loads of
toxicities. But it's not deliberately done as part of the diagnostic workup.
And so one of the things that is interesting to reason about is because we go to
the Nth degree to characterize the tumors, I think we should at least go
to the second degree to
characterize the organism. And so one of the things that this model
suggests is that if safely done, you can potentially learn something about the
patient and their personal trajectory through perturbation response.
Does that make sense?
Yeah. Thank you.
And so thank you very much for that question, and also for the wonderful compliment
that you made to all the speakers, which was a better closing remark than I could
have given. So thank you to the audience for joining
us. I hope you will join the community of cachexia
researchers if you're not already part of it, and we look forward to your personal
conversations afterwards. Thank you.